centimeters
that means i don't move my hand around i
know exactly where it's going it's
almost like facing me
so
there's the hand that's facing me as
this goes down it goes there
and then it fits
i don't believe in god but there was a
god he made this especially for this
hand to fit in
you see and i can do it without even
holding this it's um because you've
locked it yeah
okay
you can do it really quick you see
because out in the street you're gonna
have a second and that's all you've got
you can't do a big fancy in the dojo we
do lots of things we exercise and
because they're beautiful we do lots of
nice rooms in the street you know you've
got you've got a fast chance and you've
got to do it
so let's do it
so i'm looking at my
hand
when it allows me to move in
it fits perfectly in
that shoulder and i can even do this
grab one gig
i can come down here hold on
i can change
techniques
so there's lots of variants
to this right so let's try again but
your hand is sometimes going on the back
of the head and then you're changing it
and
you haven't got time it's got to be
and that's when it becomes beautiful i'm
gonna get up i'm still locking down
i'm still locking the arm
so there's a whole package of what this
can do rather than what just these can
do
let's try